- [Taylor] Ow!
- I mean, first of all,
I wanna jack your outfit.
That's so cool.
- Oh my gosh
you could have it!
- I like your dress. It's so cute.
- I didn't know sparkly
until it came in the mail
and I was like, "oh."
- Surprise.
- That's like perfect for stage. I know.
That's like the stuff I look
for, like, whenever I perform
or whatever, 'cause it catches the light.
It's really pretty.
You have the same name.
I know this is old news to
y'all, but it's so funny to me.
Is it hard, like, when people are,
does it ever get confusing
with emails, or questions?
- Yeah, what's the most difficult part?
- The mail.
- Mail?
- Yeah.
- Mail.
- "Oh, this is yours." "No, it's yours."
- Yeah.
- Yeah, like this holiday
season's gonna be tough.
Like, there's gonna be
some gifts ruined for sure.
- Opening up of the wrong.
That's Amazing.
- Yeah.
TSA, like, check-ins at
the airport, back in.
They get very.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- They're like, "We need Taylor."
And, we're like.
- [it's both. Hi.
Yes. Hi. Hello. We are both,
- They're like, no, Taylor Lautner.
And we're like, also,
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- It's just kind of it incredible
that you found each other like,
- Yeah
- I don't know, one person named Taylor,
like in my personal life.
The fact that there's, yeah.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Well now you got two.
- You got two!
- It's not as popular,
I don't think to me.
So now I'm like, yeah.
So wait,
so your first anniversary
is coming up, right?
- It is, yeah.
- Are y'all doing something fun?
First one?
(audience cheers)
- What are y'all doing?
- Yeah, we're actually
doing a fundraising gala
for our nonprofit, for our anniversary.
- Oh, well that's awesome.
Yeah!
- Yeah. We're super excited
about it.
- Did you purposely do something not
for you, like, but for others?
- I mean,
- We've been waiting to do our first gala
or fundraising evening
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- For the non-profit.
And it just felt right.
When we were talking
about what we wanted to do,
- Yeah.
For the anniversary, we were
like, should we go somewhere?
Blah, blah, blah. We're
like, or we could, you know,
- We love like, sentimental things,
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- So, like, it just, it
just like felt right.
- [Kelly] I think it's a beautiful,
I think it's a beautiful thing
to do on your anniversary.
How did y'all meet?
- My sister
- sister
- introduced us.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah. They became friends
and as soon as they became friends,
my sister literally called me
and was like, I met your future wife.
You need to,
(audience aww-ing)
you need to
to schedule a game night at your house.
I think this really was,
just thinking back on it,
this was her just trying to get an invite
to a game night that I throw.
But she was like,
you need to throw a game night,
invite a bunch of me and my friends.
Tay will be one of them
and we'll just, you
know, see what happens.
She had no idea of the setup.
- Yeah, I didn't know there was,
I just thought I was gonna play games.
- [Kelly] Are you a gamer? Do you like-
- Yeah.
- [Boy Taylor] We love-
- Oh wait yeah. I mean,
you're competitive.
- [Boy Taylor] Yeah.
- [Girl Taylor] Okay. Yeah.
See, no, I,
- What?
- I don't, I'm not super competitive.
- You are.
- I don't, I don't,
- I am,
- [Girl Taylor] I don't
let myself be competitive anymore because
- Oh.
- It's just for the best.
- Okay. No, that means you're competitive.
- That means you're competitive.
No, I don't care if I lose,
I don't care if I lose,
but I wanna compete.
I wanna play with people that wanna win.
- [Girl Taylor] Yeah.
- Yeah. We're not playing to have fun.
- Yeah. I don't want, you can have fun
and be competitive.
Yes. And what, what game was it
that y'all, what's your game night?
What do you do on game nights?
- A few different ones. Running charades.
- That's the main one.
- Running, charades.
Why did you have to make it
athletic? What, like what?
- Flipping charades.
- Wait, what, what does that mean?
What's running Charades?
- Okay. Running charades
is you have a game master
who has a list of 10
different, you know, songs,
TV shows. Movies.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I usually like that role
because I'm also competitive
and I don't want to get involved.
- Yeah.
- So I just usually be the game master.
The two teams are in different rooms
or areas of the house.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You start with the team captains,
you whisper "movie, Titanic."
They run back
to their teams in the rooms.
Charade it out.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Whoever guesses it on their team runs
to the Game Master to get the second word.
- It's whatever team finishes.
- It's a relay race
to get through the, it gets very exciting.
- I love it.
- [Girl Taylor] Yeah.
- [Boy Taylor] Yeah.
So I drafted her on my,
I was playing that night
and I drafted her on my team
and that's, that's where it started.
- Yeah.
- All over game night.
I like it. I like it.
So wait, but y'all, y'all
booked a movie theater
to like see the Eras tour?
- Yeah, we had to.
We've been in a concert.
I've been, I went a little too many times,
but it was just a fun thing
to get to do with our friends.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- Us all together, so,
- Oh no, it did look fun.
I wanna show this B roll.
So this is video of the
screening that you had.
- [Boy Taylor] Oh no.
- [Kelly] Wait
- [Girl Taylor] There he is!
- Okay, wait.
Can I tell you,
can I tell you my favorite part?
My favorite part isn't even the flip.
- (laughing) Okay.
- My favorite part is
the drag of the hand.
It is like, did you just see that?
Like, like do you, does he do that often?
Do you back flip often?
- Well, the flip or the drag of the hand.
- [Kelly] Yeah drag of the hand.
- He does, I mean, not like super often.
Not as often as he used
to, but he does flips.
- [Kelly] Trying to impress you.
- Our friends just like egg him on.
If we're ever doing something,
They're like, do the flip, and it happens.
- I say do it for as long as you can.
- [Boy Taylor] I know. I'm trying to.
- 'Cause once you hit 40,
things change.
- Yeah. Yeah. It feels
differently today. Yeah.
I paid for it the next day.
- [Kelly] Enjoy the flip.
It was rough after that evening.
- Yeah. You have to have like liquid
courage or something like it.
- Okay. So I have
to ask about something
else that Taylor posted.
So which one we'll figure out.
But here, this is, this is amazing.
So this is a bath night for one
of you, right?
- [Boy Taylor] Oh boy.
- This is a bath night
for one of you.
- [Boy Taylor] Where are
you guys getting this stuff?
- [Kelly] No. Yeah.
- [Girl Taylor] Beautiful.
- [Kelly] So do you usually bath,
do you usually, are you into bubbles?
- I am not the biggest,
she loves baths.
- [Kelly] Because they're wonderful.
- Yes, I agree.
- I have a little problem with them.
- [Kelly Laughing] It
looks like you enjoy them.
- I was in, okay, it took me 40 minutes
to set up that bath.
I was in it for three
minutes and I got hot.
And then I'm out of it and I'm
like, this is a lot of work
for like three minutes in the bath.
I used too many bubbles.
So I was like, what do I do
with them? I made a hat, but,
- [Kelly] Alright. Alright.
Let's say you're not into it. I got it.
I have to ask. I know.
I just randomly asked.
I was like, am I saying
your last name right?
I was like, wait. And I don't think I was
So it's Lautner. It's the proper way.
- The world has recently
learned that actually.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It's been a thing.
- I think so many people
said Laht-ner that I thought
- [Boy Taylor] And I never
corrected people.
- Yeah
- So they just always thought it was that
and I was like, run with it.
I don't care.
- [Kelly] So it's my,
my staff tell you, it's my biggest thing.
I always love getting
people's names. Right.
So I'm glad you did that.
- [Boy Taylor] Okay.
- We are correcting the world today.
No, but I have to ask.
So why did y'all do a podcast?
What made you wanna do that?
- That's a good question.
- Yeah.
I mean, we both have kind
of been passionate about mental
health as like individuals.
And now together, I'm a registered nurse
and I worked during C-O-V-I-D.
- Yeah, thank you. By the
way. Essential worker.
- Yeah. I never know how to
react when someone says that.
I'm like, you're welcome.
But yeah, so I obviously
that was an interesting time.
So I ended up having to leave the
hospital due to mental health reasons.
Obviously my lovely husband
has had his fair share
of mental health stuff, just being in fame
- [Kelly] Yeah
- and in the spotlight
since he was a kid.
So it's kind of just a topic
that we've grown to love
as individuals and really
learn to prioritize.
- Yeah.
- But also together,
And it's something that we're
now so passionate about.
- I think it's beautiful that you're both
open to it, you know, doing that together.
- [Girl Taylor] Yeah.
- Do you think it's helped your
relationship by doing the podcast?
- So much. So much.
- For sure.
- Yeah because I think a lot
of times it's communication right?
It's the problem in the first place.
So you're constantly communicating.
- [Girl Taylor] Yeah
- Yeah
- [Boy Taylor] No, it's really great.
[Kelly] It's like therapy.
[Boy Taylor] free therapy.
for both of us.
[Girl Taylor] That's what
we say
- [Kelly] Free therapy?
You got something there.
- Free therapy. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So you, the show,
the podcast actually inspired
the Lemon Foundation, right?
- So it's kind of flipped,
but honestly like they
all are are just kind
of one.
- [Kelly] Intertwined?
- Yeah.
I started the nonprofit about a year ago.
It's called the Lemons Foundation.
So that kind
of just started our world into
mental health and then yeah.
- We spun the squeeze off of lemons
- Yeah, it's like a, squeeze, lemons, so
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- No, that's, you get
life hands you lemons.
I like the whole play on,
- [Girl Taylor] Yeah.
- Yeah That's very, very cool.
So why did you start the blog?
Did you start it right after,
- Yeah.
- you exited nursing?
- Yeah, so I ended up leaving the hospital
and you know, I was, I was struggling
and I knew a lot of people were struggling
because it was, you know,
- [Kelly] heavy.
- Yeah, it was a hard
time for a lot of people.
So I wanted to use my
platform to kind of just share
what I was going through because I felt
open enough to kind of share.
And the response was just insane.
So many people, like,
everyone, not even just nurses,
but they were like,
that's exactly how I feel.
I feel heard, like I'm going through this.
This is so similar.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So that's kind of just how
I just kept, like sharing
what I was going through.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then that is kind of how we led
to the non-profit and the podcast.
- I love that it happened so organically.
Yeah,
- Yeah.
- Now to something fun,
does he do something that annoys you?
Does she do something that annoys you?
Are there any annoying things
that you've talked about on a
topic I'm giving you like
material for your podcast?
- [Taylor] Oh man.
Oh okay, go ahead.
- [Kelly] Uh oh!
- She's got something.
I'm terrified.
- No, no, no.
I was gonna say one that you
are, you've gotten better at
because we've talked
about it on the podcast.
The trash.
(both laughing)
- What do you do? What?
- [Girl Taylor] Like taking the trash out?
- Yeah.
- He'll take the bag out,
but he won't put a new bag in.
- Yeah.
- So it's like he'll do like part A,
but not part B of it.
- (laughing) Part A.
- And he's,
- I've gotten a lot better.
- Yeah.
Now it's like once every,
like five times he,
- [Kelly] Do you know what I'm horrible at
is I am usually good at
taking out the trash, but now living here,
it's on a different floor.
In New York, you're all levels. Right.
So now I will take it
out, put the bag back,
but I'll kind of just leave it right there
by the sink.
[Boy Taylor] Right.
- until I just make my way down
to do laundry or do something, I'm like,
I'll just do it in one trip.
[Both Taylors] Yeah.
- But then you have
garbage just hanging out
next to your kitchen
sink, which is not cool.
Yeah, it's not good. I wouldn't advise it.
I need to aim higher as
well. I don't do B either.
What is, what's something
that you feel like she,
- This is another thing that
we have talked about in the podcast
as well, is we just, we have
different communication styles.
And I feel like the
biggest thing, you know,
for a couple or a friendship
or any relationship is just
identifying your differences
in communication.
It's totally fine to, you
know, to have different styles.
But you just need to know
the other person's style.
So you can understand it,
adjust to it
instead of becoming frustrated.
- I'm a person that has
to walk away for a minute.
- Yeah,
she likes to process things.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- I go mute
I just don't say anything.
He's like, well, how do you feel?
I'm like, I have no clue
how I feel.
- Yeah. I just need a minute.
Yeah, I have to process.
- Yeah.
- So wait, if you have a baby,
will you please name it Taylor?
I just,
- If you insist.
- Just, something a T, even.
Like, I just think it
would be great. I was like,
- I've joked about naming the first child.
Tj. Taylor Junior.
- [Kelly] I'm just saying.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- Don't joke about it.
Just lean in and do it.
I love it.
I love it. My name is,
what is, it is an
androgynous name as well.
Like Kelly can be male or female.
I love though that about
names, like for kids and stuff.